- [Narrator] In this
video, I wanna explore
the question of what impact
does the environment
have on human migration.
We have a couple specific examples here,
and before we dig into
those, I want to make
a few broader points about the environment
as a historical factor.
The first of those is
simply that the environment
does have impacts on what
people are able to do,
on how and where they're able to move.
We might be looking at
is the climate suitable
for practicing agriculture?
Food production is such an important part
of human movement and human
survival in new environments.
We might look at transportation.
In the Pacific Ocean, for example,
getting from island to island requires
that you have technology
that allows you to travel
over the ocean for long distances.
The second point to
consider, more broadly,
is that human beings, when
they move to new areas,
tend to have impacts on the environment.
If they're bringing new
plants or new animals
to a place where they
haven't previously existed,
that's going to have some
impacts on the new place.
Finally, this isn't to
say that the environment
is wholly explanatory of
why history played out
the way it did, but we
also don't want to dismiss
the environment as a
potential explanatory factor.
With those bigger points in mind,
let's start by looking at a
specific example in Africa,
known as the Bantu
migration, or, more often,
the Bantu expansion
into sub-Saharan Africa.
When I say sub-Saharan Africa,
that's just the region
of Africa that is south
of the Sahara desert, and
I'll shade that in here
so that you can see
where I'm talking about.
Next, what I have is an overlay in yellow
that shows the areas of Africa
where a Bantu language is the
predominant language spoken.
The question that raises is
why does so much of sub-Saharan Africa
speak a Bantu language?
There aren't any written
records of Bantu speakers
and how they moved and
what they were thinking
when they did move, but there is evidence,
in terms of how the languages
relate to one another,
and there's also archeological evidence.
One of the helpful things about studying
the Bantu Expansion is that
from about 500, 400 B.C. on,
they were using iron tools.
They had iron-making technology,
and those tools, around with pottery
that's distinctive to
Bantu-speaking cultures,
can help archeologists
trace how Bantu speakers
spread throughout Africa over time.
Linguists who have studied
how these languages
relate to one another and archeologists
who have looked at evidence
of how Bantu speakers
migrated and moved throughout Africa
are fairly confident that they originated
somewhere here in west
Africa, and from there
spread to the south,
as well as to the east,
over to what's known as the
Great Lakes Region of Africa.
Then, from there, farther south again.
That tells us how people
moved through Africa.
What pattern did they follow?
The next question we wanna
try and figure out the answer
to is why did they migrate
to the places that they did?
One thing that we know
about Bantu-speaking peoples
is that they tended to
have fairly consistent
and common agricultural practices.
Among the crops that they were growing
were
millet
and sorghum.
Once they got to the great lakes region
and started moving
south, you also see them
adopting cattle herding.
Pictures of the cattle that they would've
probably had here.
What these crops and these
cattle have in common,
all of them tend to thrive in what's known
as a tropical savanna, or a
semi-tropical savanna climate.
Sub-Saharan Africa, with the exception
of this rainforest region here,
and this high desert down in the south,
is largely tropical, or
semi-tropical, savanna.
When we put the overlay back
up of where Bantu-speakers
are the majority, we can
see that sort of corresponds
with those climate variations.
You see them populate
really all of the areas
that are favorable to their
agricultural practices.
That should make sense.
If we think about migration
as a risk-reward calculation,
you need to make sure that any place
that you're migrating to
is gonna be able to provide you with food.
To bring that back to our big theme
of how does environment impact migration,
we really see in the Bantu Expansion
the role of climate affecting
what kind of agriculture
is possible, and that
determines what areas
look attractive for migration.
The next region we want to look at,
the next migration we want to study
is that of people moving
throughout the Pacific Islands.
You can see the path this
migration probably took here.
When we talk about
expansion in the Pacific,
we're looking at
something somewhat similar
to the Bantu Expansion in Africa,
and that, again, we don't
have any written records
from the people who moved here,
so again, we're relying on
linguistic, or language-based,
evidence, as well as
archeological evidence.
This evidence helps us sort of divide up
the Pacific into three distinct regions.
We have what's called Malanesia in blue,
and Micronesia in red,
and Polynesia in purple.
Again, these are all people
who were originally speaking
some sort of Austronesian language,
very similar culturally,
but they can look at
how there have been small
changes in cultural artifacts,
changes in languages, even in the genetics
of the people and the animals
in different regions of the Pacific,
to kind of get a sense of where they were
at what time, and that
gives us this probable route
of migration that we saw.
Thinking again about environment
impacting this migration
into the Pacific Ocean,
there are a couple of important factors.
The first and obvious one
is that getting across
large stretches of ocean is going to pose
a difficulty; it's an obstacle.
The way that people overcame
this obstacle in the Pacific,
was they came up with
better sailing technology.
I can pull up here a picture
of a re-creation of a catamaran.
This technology was really important
for traveling long distances in the ocean
because, to get out in the open ocean,
you need a sturdy, a durable ship
that's gonna hold up to wind and waves.
Even though this is a modern re-creation,
it gives us a good sense of
what the technology was like.
You can see how that would
be a more durable craft
than, say, a canoe by itself.
This allows people to
travel between islands.
The other issue, environmentally speaking,
that poses an obstacle to
expansion in the Pacific
is that a lot of these
islands are really small.
You're probably noticing that some of them
are quite difficult to see
on the satellite image,
and they don't have a lot of arable,
or farmable, land on them,
and so they can't support
large populations,
and this is probably one
reason why there is continued
expansion in the Pacific
over a long period of time,
is because the islands
themselves can't support
very large populations.
If a population grows to a certain point,
some people have to leave.
To deal with this fact that the islands
didn't provide a lot of natural food,
people would bring their
own food supplies with them.
They'd bring things like
sweet potatoes and yams
and taro root, and they
would bring animals as well,
so chickens, and you have a picture here,
this is what's called a
Southeast Asian red junglefowl,
and it's the precursor
to domestic chickens.
It can give you a sense of what
some of these chickens
probably looked like.
They brought pigs.
They also had a small breed of dog.
The dog breed is extinct now,
but we have some pictures that were drawn
by some early European
explorers of the Pacific.
People would bring these items with them.
They'd bring these animals with
them onto these new islands.
They would grow the crops.
They would raise the animals
and use them as a food source.
To go back to our original list
of big takeaways, this gets
into this idea of environmental
impact of bringing these
new plants and animals.
What happens is that
people bring these plants,
they bring these animals
that are not native
to these islands onto
these islands and use them.
They farm them; they raise them for food;
and in most cases, people
are able to sort of
strike a balance of
maintaining a food supply
with these crops and
animals that they've brought
and not destroying the island environment,
because, obviously, that
would have consequences
for their ability to
continue to live there.
Hopefully, it's clear at this point
that environment definitely played a role
in these migrations, in these expansions.
Certainly, this isn't only
about environmental factors,
but in both cases, it
would be very difficult
to explain what happened
if you didn't include
these environmental factors.